I want to read you an article from LA
Times this is October of 2004 the title
of the article is George Soros The God
Who carries around some dangerous demons
here's what he says in the interview he
says I fancied myself as some kind of
God if truth be known I carried some
rather potent Messianic fantasies with
me from childhood which I felt I had to
control otherwise they might get me in
trouble it is a sort of disease when you
consider yourself some kind of God the
creator of everything are you ready
here's how he finishes it but I feel
comfortable about it now since I began
to live it out today
we're going to learn more about George
Soros
foreign
so if you get value from this video give
it a thumbs up subscribe to the channel
let's get right into it why do we need
to learn about this man named George
Soros who's 92 years old why would you
be intimidated by this guy so what if
he's made somewhere between 50 to 70
billion dollars in his career and
currently his net worth is seven billion
dollars yeah he's given 32 billion
dollars to different organizations such
as open Society organization and some
others yeah he supported a lot of
different presidents a lot of different
candidates a lot of different people why
are people so scared of him is this guy
Puppet Master is he evil is he a good
person is he a bad person is he a
humanitarian maybe he's just a father
maybe he just wants to support some
cause why are you so worried about him
all of those are good questions today
we're going to study his childhood
upbringing as an adult how we became an
investor where he made all the money
Carl popper who is this Carl popper guy
and who he's given money to over the
years let's get right into it all right
so he was born August 1930 in Budapest
Hungary originally named Georgie
Schwartz but his father later changed a
family surname to Soros a more Hungarian
sounding name to protect them from
increasing anti-semitic sentiment in
Hungary his father thibodar was a lawyer
and a passionate promoter of Esperanto
an artificial language created in the
late 19th century intended to Foster
Harmony between people from different
cultures his father's decision to teach
Esperanto was an early indication of
commitment to an open-mindedness and
understanding of different cultures that
George would carry into his later life
George Soros was 14 during the Nazi
occupation of Hungary in 1944 his father
secured false identities for the family
identifying themselves as Christians
George Soros was tasked with being a
courier who helped Nazis identify Jews
and confiscate their property and in a
1998 60-minute interview he was asked if
this was a traumatizing experience and
this is how you responded my
understanding is that you went out with
this protector of yours who swore that
you were his adopted God's son yes
went out in fact and helped in the
confiscation of property from the Jews
that's right
yes I mean that's that sounds uh like an
experience that would send lots of
people to the psychiatric couch for many
many years
was it difficult
not not at all not at all so a lot of
people who didn't know who George Soros
was they watched his interview and they
said this this guy sounds like a
sociopath how could you say something
like that some other said well maybe he
was numb as a 14 year old imagine you're
going through it and you see stuff like
that by the way at the same time when
this is taking place he had another
traumatic experience to the liberators
that were helping them out Russian
liberators they raped his mother and his
mother talked about it so this kid all
this pain all this anger all this
frustration all these experiences all
happen and at the same time you have to
live a fake life so they don't kill you
act like you're a Christian help the
Nazis find Jews your mom's going through
it as you're working with Russians all
of that together at a young age what
does that do to you so now let's look at
George source as a young adult after the
war Hungary fell under the Communist
rule in 1947 Soros left hungry for
England he worked as a waiter and a
railway Porter to support his studies at
the London School of Economics during
this time he meets the man that had the
most influence in his life this is
according to his words Carl popper now
who is Carl popper Carl Papa Was a
philosopher of Science and
epistemologist best known for his
principle of falsifiability so what did
Carl papa really believe in these are
some of the philosophies that he had
number one falsifiability he proposed
that for a theory to be considered
scientific it must be potentially
falsifiable this means there must be a
potential observation or experiment that
could prove the theory false number two
the principle of falsifiability was
designed to solve the demarcation
problem the problem of distinguishing
between science and non-science or
pseudoscience number three critique of
historicism he argued against the idea
that history unfolds according to
predictable laws or patterns he promoted
the idea that human actions can
significantly influence the course of
history for open Society is what he
believed in which by the way later on
sorrow starts a foundation called open
Society Foundation here's what open
society means to crop Hopper the open
society and its enemies popper defended
liberal democracy and criticized
totalitarianism he depicted Democratic
societies as open self-correcting
systems and last Point influence and
critique while Popper's philosophy has
been influential it has been subject to
debate and critique despite this he
remains one of the most widely read
philosophers of the 20th century so so
those were his philosophies core proper
but this is how he influenced short
Sorrows so number one was the philosophy
of open Society keep in mind this is in
the late 40s early 50s instead of
promoting totalitarian regimes such as
communism and fascism it was about
replacing you with individual Freedom
Democratic governance and a flexible
changing social and economic structure
this is what he wanted to do number two
follow billism the belief that all
knowledge is tentative provisional and
subject to Revision in light of new
evidence this influence Soros investment
strategy and he always talks about the
fact that he was ready to adjust his
positions if the facts changed number
three is critical thinking so Soros
adopted this in his investment strategy
where he was often willing to go against
conventional wisdom but also in its
philanthropic activities encouraging
open debate and discussion and last man
at least humanitarian efforts this has
significantly influenced Source
philanthropic efforts which has focused
on civil society education and human
rights around the globe or at least
that's what he claims to focus on so
while he's getting clear on his
philosophies he's picking up from Carl
poppara at the same time Europe is in
shambles the Marshall Plan is being
executed from U.S by George Marshall
secretary of state they're sending 13 to
15 billion hours to Europe in fuel food
different ways to help out he's seen the
same there may be a need for a global
Marshall Plan I'd love to be a part of
that that also kind of inspired him a
little bit so we just learned a little
bit about his childhood adulthood and
how his philosophies are getting clear
now let's look at how he doesn't Finance
so let me put it to you this way from
1970 to 2000 if you had to throw names
out there on who are the best money
managers you would find a name Buffett
you would find the name Soros and later
on you would find the name dalio from
1970 to 2000 he starts a fund called
Quantum fund it's still around but
during that period average annual rate
of return 30 percent and yet some years
that was 60 plus percent every year and
of course it help in many cases when
these guys were operating on offshore
laws not having to abide by SEC U.S tax
code all the stuff that we had going on
here that is a form of an edge that he
had but at the same time he was either
the best or one of the top three best
during his time so now Soros had two
things when he came out to his
investment philosophy one of it was
fallability and the other one was
reflexivity let's look at both number
one the theory of fallibility is a
concept stemmed from the philosophical
understanding that it's impossible to
achieve perfect knowledge in other words
humans are inherently flawed in their
understanding and judgment the theory is
mainly used to explain the limitations
of human comprehension and decision
making in complex systems like economics
this fall ability is often magnified by
cognitive biases incomplete information
and the emotions of the individual and
the second theory was the theory of
reflexivity and here's what reflexivity
is it's the idea that people's
perception and beliefs influence their
decision making which in turn impacts
the state of the world changing the
fundamentals that they are trying to
understand this then further Alters
their perceptions and beliefs creating a
continuous reflexive feedback loop he
openly talks about how he used some of
these philosophies to actually
manipulate the markets in his favor and
make billions of dollars we'll look at a
couple of the times he did this but he
said this once in his book this is what
makes propaganda so effective because
the complexity of the world we live in
exceeds our ability to understand it
confronted by a reality of extreme
complexity we are obligated to resort to
various methods of simplification pretty
wild sharp shrewd you can call a lot of
different names but here's how we use
those philosophies to make billions
number one the British pound in 1992
this is the most famous example George
Soros used to influence the market by
betting against the British pound in 92
he believed that the pound was
overvalued and that the British
government would have to devalue the
currency it was proven right when the
British government was forced to
withdraw the pound from the European
exchange rate mechanism Soros bet 10
billion and made a profit of one billion
dollars from this trade nicknamed the
man who broke the bank of England
according to the shadow party book Soros
admits that this bed was taking money
out of the pockets of British taxpayer
but says if I had taken social
consequence into account it would have
thrown off my risk reward calculation
and profits would have been refused can
you imagine thinking that way
it's pretty wild I'm gonna give you four
other examples where it'll validate his
reflexivity or his fallibility
philosophy the second one would be the
German Deutsche Mark in 1993 he wrote a
letter to the times of London stating
that he expected the mark to fall
against all major currencies which
immediately triggered Panic selling
again this is reflexivity the next one
Asian financial crisis in 1997 during
the Asian financial crisis Soros
investment activities were blamed by
some for exasperating the crisis
Malaysia's then prime minister mahathir
Mohammed accused Soros of destabilizing
regional economies through currency
speculation then he also did something
similar in Russia the Russian Ruble 1998
he told Financial Times of London that
Russia should devalue the ruble by 15 to
25 percent causing Widespread Panic
selling and the last example here's a
dollar in 2004 Soros announced a short
position against the dollar on CNN at a
time when the dollar had been quickly
declining against the Euro pushing the
dollar down even further so this was his
way of making money was one of the ways
finding ways to manipulate the market
now a lot of other people have done it
but he mastered it took it to a whole
different level and then eventually in
1907 late 70s when his net worth was 25
million dollars he says he felt a
certain sense of emptiness and that's
where you know the political activist in
him came out the philanthropy came out
and in many column the wealthiest
political activists of all time and
these are some of the projects He funded
so remember the word open Society he
picked up earlier from Carl popper later
on in April of 1993 he starts the open
Society foundation and then in 2017 open
Society Foundation announced that Soros
had transferred 18 billion dollars of
his fortune to open Society making it a
total of 32 billion dollars he had given
to open Society Foundation since 1984.
in case you missed it one more time 32
billion hours that's 32 billion dollars
of his own money not hey let's go get
raise money his own money he put into it
and whether it's through its open
Society Foundation or other ways of
giving money he contributed and
influenced media politics colleges
universe so let me just kind of share
with you some of the numbers so you kind
of have an idea and in 2004 Sora spent
more than 27 million dollars just to
help defeat President Bush if it's
colleges where open Society spend 50
million dollars per year to informs
colleges between 2014 to 2018 Soros
donated 184 million dollars to 171
colleges in 51 countries that's 10
percent of all foundations during that
time they also created open Society
University network but he knew one of
the ways to influence was to get
colleges and universities and when you
give that kind of money those
universities kind of have to listen to
what you have to say or media he set a
lifelong fascination with media he has
connections with more than 30 mainstream
news outlets it's including New York
Times waipo Associated Press CNN and ABC
prominent journalists like ABC's
Christiane Amanpour New York Times
executive editor Joe Abramson and former
post editor now Vice President Len
Downey served on the boards of
operations that take Soros cash a 2011
estimate indicates that media
organizations influenced by Soros have a
reach of an estimated 300 million people
per month in end of q1 of 2021 Soros
largest stock holding was Liberty
Broadband over 600 million dollars and
Liberty Broadband largest asset is
Charter Communications and its
subsidiaries which together are the
second largest cable operator in the U.S
another large holding cases Viacom CBS
subsiders include Paramount Pictures and
Simon and Schuster which means he also
influences books what's being bought
what's not being bought what will
publish what we won't publish that's a
lot of power there in media and recently
he just made an offer to buy Vice for
400 million dollars another one is Trump
obviously him and Trump are not going
out there golfing together and they're
not best friends he cannot stand Trump
he once said nationalism is the great
threat of the open Society he said this
at World economic Forum World economic
Forum Klaus Schwab he says that there of
course world economic forum is not a fan
of trump and he called Trump the
ultimate narcissist and said there's
nothing more important than defeating
him in 2020 election it's kind of weird
when you call somebody a narcissist when
you think you literally you think you're
God isn't the ultimate narcissist
somebody that thinks they're God I don't
know if I know anybody in my life I've
met that say Hey I'm God I feel like I
finally am living my life where I'm like
God but I'm not a narcissist I'm a very
humble man that's what I am yeah I think
it's fair to say that I'm also not
saying Trump is not a narcissist at this
Level Playing Field you can't call
anybody a narcissist because everybody
has a little bit of it to get to this
level so there's a lot of things you can
call people narcissists is probably not
one of them because everybody in the
room is one so obviously seeing a guy
like Trump being president wasn't
something that was exciting for him AP
News once said about a Mainland voting
June 18 2020 a network of deep pocketed
Progressive donors are launching a 59
million dollar effort to encourage
people of color to vote by mail
philanthropic organizations including
Ford foundation and George Soros open
Society to raise the money that's in
2000 election he was a part of it to
help with that he's pretty much been
involved in every single election since
2000 doing his best to help Al Gore be
George Bush which obviously didn't
happen that was a failed one in 2004 he
reportedly spent 27 million dollars
trying to defeat George Bush with John
Kerry 2008 he supported Barack Obama
2012 he continued to support Barack
Obama 2016 he spent 22 million dollars
supporting Hillary Clinton and other
Democratic candidates in 2020 spent 70
million dollars trying to help Biden
beat Trump which he succeeded and if
that's not enough he's so strategic he
even goes after District Attorneys
matter of fact George Soros funded DA's
represent 20 percent of Americans okay
he funneled 40 million dollars into
local races to elect 75 Progressive
prosecutors over the last decade so some
of you may be watching St Pat what's the
big deal this guy became a billionaire
he became Rich he gave 32 billion
dollars who cares what he wants to give
his money to let him give his money to
whatever he wants to give it to him I
don't I don't say anything's wrong with
that if that's what he wants to do more
power to him that's his cause he's doing
what he's doing he's got five kids
family all this stuff and he supports
his cause but here's the problem the
problem is what do you believe in so the
other day we're having a conversation
the conversation went this way a
nationalist gets a lot of criticism
you're a nationalist if you love America
okay fair what is the antonym of being a
nationalist a globalist well if I'm a
nationalist you're a globalist why do we
need borders do we just have open
Society where there's no borders because
these men who are inspired and so
ambitious they want to control the world
what is your job to do lead your family
protect your home protect your borders
protect your nation
if you're a nationalist this guy doesn't
support your philosophy if you're a
globalist this guy supports your
philosophy you pick and choose which one
you want to be and by the way some
people are saying well wait till he dies
it's going to be all right it's going to
be this now this stuff people feel well
this guy's gonna do this that guy's
going everything's gonna like Oprah
Winfrey Point said all these Republicans
need to die off and then everything's
going to be normal that's not how life
Works he's got a 38 year old son named
Alexander who has visited the Biden
White House 14 times since he's been in
office met with everybody there whether
it's the National Security advisor or
advisors to Biden's then chief of staff
for National Security advisors executive
assistant it doesn't matter he is
ambitious and he's his father's son and
he's going to continue the Legacy so
this Sorrows name ain't going away but
it's definitely something and someone
you need to know more about if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel I got
another video I want you to watch it's
titled the dangers of cbdc if you've
never watched it click here to watch it
take everybody bye-bye
thank you